[Musik]
hallo herz willkommen sallys welt heute
gibt es wieder ein rezept aus der
kategorie nachgemacht original trifft
zählen heute werde ich nämlich dieses
oft cakes nachmachen wie kind auch jeder
kennt jeder
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
jemand gibt er sie nicht kennen ja ich
glaub auch die gibt sehen wir
verschiedenen geschmacksrichtungen ich
kenne auch dem team wäre orange glaubens
oranges changes kann aber jetzt habe ich
hier heimische früchte also mit
johannisbeeren auch dabei und ich hab
das ganze ist leutselig ich hatte das
ganze hier auch zubereitet aus
biskuitteig als biscuit masse dann habe
ich eine boxeinlage gemacht um das ganze
mit peter kuvertüre überzogen
einmal im miniformat und einmal ein
bisschen größer und ich finds echt beide
so verkohlt vor allem schmecken sehr
lecker und sind wichtig ein bisschen ja
genau und ich weiß nicht was es gesünder
ist oder das eigentlich schon ein ich
wollte einfach mal machen
foto larmann zuschauer das gerne gehen
und ich es auch cool finde mal was oft
zu problemen
also ich sage ich jetzt mal der zutaten
verdeckt ist mitmachen und können jetzt
haben also dass so was kann die ganze
woche nicht trainiert mein erster mensch
den biskuit brauche ich viel eiweiß eine
prise salz 4 eigelb 100 gramm zucker
etwas vanille extrakt und 100 gramm mehl
zuerst nämlich das eiweiß umschlag ist
jetzt in einer schüssel steigt und das
geht am besten mit einer prise salz
[Musik]
und sobald er ein schnee streif ist gebe
ich noch die hälfte des zuckers mit dazu
und ruin für eine minute weiter jetzt
ist er eigentlich fest den schneebesen
kann ich einfach weitere nutzen und gäbe
ist sie in der schüssel rein und kann
jetzt hier eigelb zucker und vanille
extrakt kriegen schwimmen
[Musik]
die eier zucker masse ist es schön
cremig
jetzt kommt hier das mehl mit dazu das
widget gesiebt und dann habe ich ganz
vorsichtig unter
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich auch den eischnee
unterheben und das ganze mache ich
einfach in mehreren portionen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier einen einweg
spritzbeutel und vorne in der große loch
thüle und den stuhl sitzt hier in den
schutz beutel ständer und schon jetzt
die masse einfüllen
[Musik]
das habe ich dem spritzbeutel hinten
verschlossen in dem ich ihn einfach zug
gedreht habe ich jetzt mit backpapier
und zwar nämlich jetzt papieren
denn ich habe auch die rückseite bereits
kreise auf gemahnt und das ganze einfach
auf mein blog blog blech gewitzt und die
kreise haben denn durchmesser von 3,5 cm
und dienen einfach so ein bisschen als
orientierung kann ich hier den bisher
auf spritzen
[Musik]
jetzt denke ich meinen finger in wasser
man kann jetzt hier oben anfangen die
spitzen ein bisschen flach drücken
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen beide fläche
gleichzeitig in den ofen ich habe
nämlich den oben bereits auf heißluft
eingestellt 190 grad kann jetzt hier
einen weiter und ein blech weiter oben
einsetzen und dann brauchen die biscuits
etwa jahr etwa 15 minuten bis die
oberfläche etwas goldbraun sind wo sie
sollen natürlich auch ein bisschen
ausdrucken und daher heißluft
so sehen jetzt die soft cakes aus und
ich hab's dir ein bisschen kürzer backen
lassen ist einfach auf die bräunung
achten sie sollten natürlich nicht zu
dunkel werden jetzt sind sie bereits
abgekühlt und ich kann dir jetzt hier
auf der seite stehen lassen und werde
jetzt die frucht einlage machen genau in
den original six hat man auch so ein
gelee mit dabei und das ist auch
wirklich super lecker man hat an den
bestbieter kreative und dann das
das werde ich jetzt selbst zubereiten
und nehme jetzt dafür 500 milliliter
saft da habe ich jetzt einfach einen
roten multivitaminsaft genommen und ein
päckchen agathes und 15 gramm
es gebe ich es beides hier in einen job
ein kann das jetzt miteinander verrühren
und lasst die mischung aufkochen und
dann mindestens zwei minuten lang
spielen und kochen
[Musik]
die masse durfte jetzt kochen und jetzt
habe ich sie um gefüllt damit sie ein
bisschen abkühlen kann und habe in der
zwischenzeit auch die breit genutzt und
habe diese kleinen biscuits von der bak
vor allem vom backpapier abgelöst die
haben jetzt hier so eine kleine
markierung zeigt die waren einfach noch
nicht lange genug getrockneten haben ein
bisschen und dem backpapier geklebt aber
das ist gar nicht schlimm denn es ist ja
sowieso die innenseite und dann sieht
man sich später nicht
jetzt brauche ich ein gefäß für das
gelee dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach in
einen tortenring ich habe jetzt hier
einen torten retter drunter und eine
folie frischhaltefolie und werde jetzt
im ringen auf etwa 26 cm durchmesser
einstellen und das ganze jetzt ein
bisschen einschlagen denn das ist eine
ganz flüssige masse und kann einfach
passieren dass ein bisschen was ausläuft
wir können aber auch im prinzip jede
beliebige form nehmen
hauptsache kleidet sich vorher mit folie
aus bei mir das später auch wieder
rauskommen und jetzt wird es einfach 4 1
geführt und dann habe ich so eine dicke
von etwa 2 bis 3 mm bis heute läuft ein
bisschen raus deswegen habe ich aber
auch die folie da und jetzt werde ich es
schnell einfrieren und für etwa eine
halbe stunde im giftschrank lassen so
die frucht ein nagel ist gefroren ich
habe jetzt aber auch kurz schon ein
bisschen wieder anschauen lassen damit
sie einfach nicht zu kalt ist
so sieht das ist lecker ausländer pro
team einfach so gibt nämlich die soft
facts und jetzt habe ich jetzt bei
ausstecher und zwar ist er eine
ausstecher ein bisschen kleiner als die
großen unter anderem passt eben genauso
auf die anderen so oft ist es einfach
ein bisschen kleiner
so müssen die auch sein und ich muss
jetzt schnell arbeiten denn hier werden
schon ein paar kekse klaus meine gags
und in der zwischenzeit habe ich jetzt
hier schon mal kurator geschmolzen
ich habe 200 gramm zar peter kuratoren
fein gehackt und zwei drittel davon über
dem heißen aber nicht kochenden
wasserbad erwärmt und danach einfach ein
drittel noch rein gehört mit bisschen
kokosfett damit auch ein schönes land
hat die familie jetzt einmal schwimmen
ein schoko bürger machen und jetzt kann
ich mithilfe der ausstellern einfach
hier dieser masse ausstechen
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich die einfach hier
drauflegen und wird dann mit der chöre
über giessen ok
[Musik]
so sehen die software jetzt aus ich habe
natürlich abholen lassen damit die
kuvertüre auch festwirt möchtest du
verwehren unbedingt sind im prinzip hat
er schon probiert denn er hat sich schon
etwas glaubt ist abgezielt probier sie
ich komme mir dem großen dann rein
reifen und den die kamera als muss ich
sagen dass ihr kann man halt mal deshalb
sie wirklich hingekriegt wahnsinnig weil
das ist wirklich im original genauso
lasst euch mal ein originales ausgepackt
zum sozialen natürlich probieren bemerkt
es ist ein bisschen ruhiger aber es ist
es ist fast identisch
das muss auch hinkriegen dass so ein tag
so hinkriegt stärken hier das original
gras schmidt genau gleich ja auch
richtig gut und man kann ja als saft
nehmen was man möchte
ich muss sagen also der aufwand es ging
also toffifee muss ich sagen war
aufwendiger oder riesling sneaker von da
her ging es aber ich weiß die originale
trotzdem aufgabe aber ich schliesse
wahnsinn die illusion und sagst du man
einen zuschauer großgörschen ausgedacht
ja ich hab mir schon am ausgedachten
heute morgen halt ausprobiert und beim
ersten mal gleich funktioniert ja weil
das ist ein biskuit teig und dann habe
ich mir gedacht ich vielleicht also ganz
ehrlich al somali probiere das die ganze
fahre oder irgendwie du machst ziemlich
einmalig funktionieren ohne schmeckt
genau gleich ja und was ich hier sogar
noch besser finde ich dass sie schon
knackig nachrichten
und ob er ihn als rechtmässigen akku auf
irgend wann und was ich auch muss ich
sagen besser finde ich habe hier in der
zuchtanlage keinen zucker mit dabei das
heißt sie sind es auch nicht zu süß also
macht wirklich nur den saft den zucker
aus den früchten und eben imbiss wird
und in der schokolade mit keinen
zusätzlichen zucker in der füllung mal
dass ich mir ein bisschen zu wenig
bürger die ankurbelung das ganze kann
man sich auch aus einem großen softpack
machen finde ich auch ich das cool
vor allem kann man dann stück herunter
schneiden und das ganze dann noch weiter
und immer gespannt wer der erste ist ja
das nachmachen und facebook bild boss ja
da bin ich jetzt auch gespannt und ich
wünsche euch schon mal ganz schön spaß
nach wacken
unglaublich
[Musik]
jetzt meine bürger ein bisschen versaut
pr.com bisschen viel steinen der clovis
ist der beste markt oder und die zutaten
genau von logos oder aber man macht